meteorologists are calling it a
one-center generation weather event it's
complicating the once in a Year
festivities to say the least
a pre-Christmas Mass mobilization has
been stalled by high winds heavy
snowfall and flooding in freezing
temperatures a number of cities have
declared states of emergency including
New York I called it a kitchen sink
storm because it is throwing everything
at us but the kitchen sink
we've had ice
flooding
snow
freezing temperatures
and everything that mother nature could
Wallop at us this weekend I declared a
state of emergency that took a place
effect at 6am this morning the Arctic
Blast has forced the cancellation of
several thousand flights and Counting
the travel chaos is reflected on the
roads too with motorists stranded in
white out conditions
more than 200 million people are under
some form of weather advisory that's 60
percent of the U.S population struck by
the phenomenon dubbed a bomb cyclone
the storm intensifies really quickly you
can get very damaging winds and then the
winds over the water can create can move
water around so you get huge waves storm
surge coastal flooding can be pretty
terrible
the severe cold brings disruption but
also danger to life there have been
several deaths in Houston Texas a
homeless man in a wheelchair fell into a
fire pit overnight he was found dead by
firefighters called to the scene
in the cold temperatures a number of
cities including Portland in Oregon have
declared a state of emergency opening
extra shelters for homeless people
more than a million people have had
their power cut off as the storm battles
through North America before Christmas
it's seriously it's dangerously cold I
mean
I would advise anyone if you don't have
to be out don't go out and if you do go
out well you need to
bundle up there is no right time for
conditions like these it's certainly not
right now James Matthews Sky News in
Washington